I said look uh regardless of whether you
think Trump should be the nominee we the
real question to ask is is if to santis
is so manifestly Superior in the ways
that you describe why is Trump leading
overwhelmingly in other words what is it
that the Republican base thinks about
Trump that you're missing and and I
think the answer very simply is the
Republican PA base thinks that Trump won
the 2020 election and and for that
reason alone the Republican base thinks
this guy deserves another shot because
he is the the legitimate winner of the
last one so the idea of saying okay well
too bad for him let's just give it a
someone else there's a reluctance to go
there without fully Rel litigating that
what would you what would you if if you
were sitting with Trump what would you
say to him regarding why wouldn't they
do it again I would simp I would simply
say that the Republican National
Committee with a impressive battery of
lawyers needs to go go state by state
and insist and this is especially true
in all the swing States 24-hour
surveillance on all the drop boxes that
alone that alone will kill the problem
of mules because because you have the
surveillance I mean the simple truth of
it is with with cell phone geot tracking
and surveillance you can bust that
operation I mean we busted it to a
degree but law enforcement could have
busted It Wide Open do you have any
reason to think that he's done that or
that the RNC has done that I I actually
don't know and In fairness it's In
fairness it's not because it's In
fairness it's because and there are
people who come to me and say denes what
are you doing to fix voter fraud and I
go well listen my job is done I made a
movie and the point of the movie is to
hand off to you guys there are
organizations that deal with this in and
day in and day out and so in a sense I
I've not fallen behind on that topic as
I pivoted to the to the topic of the
police state I have reason to believe
that they're now aware of it they've
certainly got the team they've raised a
lot of money on this issue um there are
groups like through the vote that do
this sort of day in and day out so I'm
hopeful that it's going to be better but
you know am I naive enough to think that
they fixed it all no I think knowing
just the GOP I mean I've lived with the
GOP for 30 years they're probably doing
a half ass job and so I'm going to
consider the problem like half fixed
right which half fixed probably doesn't
do it and by the way Des santis could be
the nominee and they would still have
those problems the the thing that I
would say would be different in that
regard is sort of an offshoot of what
you said on pool's podcast a week or two
ago which I thought was quite good his
operational efficiency I think would
start lending itself to to taking care
of some of that stuff can actually can
you just uh point I was making you were
talking Trump I was on with an cter and
you know uh and an was sort of railing
about Trump and and she was a huge Trump
person at one point she was she was the
first one that said it's gonna happen
she was a huge trumpster I mean I think
she even wrote a book which I wouldn't
put you know in Trump we trust you know
anyway um and I I was making the point I
said look uh regardless of whether you
think Trump should be the nominee we the
real question to ask is is if dtis is so
manifestly Superior in the ways that you
describe why is Trump leading
overwhelmingly in other words what is it
that the Republican base thinks about
Trump that you're missing and and I
think the answer very simply is the
Republican PA Bas thinks that Trump won
the 2020 election and and for that
reason alone the Republican base thinks
this guy deserves another shot because
he is the the legitimate winner of the
last one so the idea of saying okay well
too bad for him let's just give it to
someone else there's a reluctance to go
there but the second point I made is is
just a political point and I and I this
is something I noticed going back to the
days of Reagan there are some
politicians who have this kind of Larger
than Life quality which is very evident
I mean when we if you're in a large
Ballroom of a thousand people and Reagan
walked in the room it was unbelievable
to see everything go silent every head
turn and and even Reagan I noticed I
mean this is maybe part of his Hollywood
he's very aware of this and he was very
careful he you know just the way he held
himself the way he cocked his head he
knew that he was under sort of
observation now there are other people
who are really good guys and I saw this
with a lot of raganit who were sort of
they were essentially clones of Reagan
on policy issues but they just didn't
have that janas qua they just didn't
have that star equality it they just
have that it that's it and so with this
so my point to an was that sort of you
know if you could combine the kind of
Charisma of trump with the ruthless
operational efficiency of disantis
that's kind of what I think everyone is
looking for yeah well that's why to me
regardless of who I want to be the
nominee it's been so disappointing
because it's like man the all the pieces
are here we could have the most United
party exactly probably well certainly in
my lifetime or maybe maybe not since
Reagan Reagan re-election or something I
mean I'm not advising Trump but if I
were I'd be like listen you know the
first thing to do and this is actually
what a big man does is call up to santis
and sit sit down and say you know what
we would make an unbelievable team and
um not to mention the fact that you know
how do you when you think about people
who say things like let's defund the FBI
let's take down the FBI I say to myself
well we need an FBI I mean we need a law
enforcement agency that goes out to
organize crime crime um the FBI does a
lot of good things so how do you sort of
fix the FBI it's not a simple matter of
I'm going to fire the Christopher Ray
and put in a new guy somebody needs to
burrow into the FBI and root out the bad
guys because there's a corrupt structure
of incentives that goes all the way down
that makes even the good people act
badly and so you need a bureaucratic
infighter to do that so imagine if Trump
were to say to DeSantis you are my man
to drain the swamp but I need you to go
into the swamp uh and you're the guy to
do it and uh and clean it up because I
that's actually not my temperament I
have the intention and I now have of
course the determination but see this is
this is a mature politics and this is
what a mature party would do but the
fact that it's not happening it doesn't
mean to me it won't happen but I share
your you know exasperation that it
doesn't seem to be headed in that
direction right you could even take a
guy like RFK to me and send him to go
fix the gencies even though I have big
political disagreements with him it's
like that's a guy who's fighting a lot
of the same battles that you're talking
about when it came to co overreach and
everything else like he's a lawyer he
seems to get it like send him in I mean
think think of the value it would be to
Trump to find a prominent Democrat and
basically say this guy is going to be
like myar on coid and free speech and
having a Democrat I mean there's a
strategic value to all this which you
know you think our side would understand
by now um but uh
so this is a broader frustration I have
and and I think if there's one message I
have implicit in police state it's not
in the movie but it's it I think it's
the clear take-home value of the movie
is that the spine of the Republicans
needs to be stiffened and Republicans
also need to fight smarter because they
um uh they're we up against something I
don't know an alternative to the
Republican party and I don't really
sympathize with people who talk about a
third party or we need some other
because this is the mechanism we have
and uh and it's a mechanism with a great
history and it's one that could be very
effective if we use the power Just the
power that we already have right now
yeah do you sometimes think and again as
a guy that lives in Texas and be here in
Florida that the the micro version of it
the experiment of America the state part
of it'll work we have an incredibly
powerful Republican party here we we
basically don't have a Democrat Party
anymore in Florida um you're not quite
at that level in Texas but like you've
got a functional state that it'll just
work in some places and it won't work in
others but of course that ever
encroachment I mean I think that's right
I I I do think that the decentralization
of power is an important theme for us
because we you know I think hakus the
phrase a framework of competing Utopias
Hey listen you know what you have a
bunch of states and the 50 states are
doing a lot of different things some are
going to work and some aren't to me
what's interesting about the Democrats
is that they are showing creatively
imaginative ways to ruin places in
different ways so I just saw something
very about the the San Francisco model
versus the Chicago model so the San
Francisco model is that you don't have
driveby shootings where people you have
a massive homicide rate the San
Francisco model is let us have a
lowgrade criminality but spread it
throughout the city you cannot Escape it
you know what I mean it's everywhere
yeah some psycho homeless guy is going
to come up to you and punch you or grab
a chicken wing off your plate um but it
allows the Liberals to say well listen
you know I'm being compassionate and the
guys has issues now the Chicago model is
that you have just like open gunfire but
interestingly it's not all over Chicago
it's in it's in the black areas it's in
the baros it's in certain pockets and so
the progressive can say well you know
it's not affecting me it's not in my
neighborhood Bam Bam Bam you know
somebody else is getting killed so it it
creat it's happening at their
universities now except it's exactly so
it they even ultimately suffer the creep
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop screaming check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell